all right uh opt-out's a major issue
last year for college players and for
plenty of professional players nearly 70
nfl players opted out it was a confusing
time it was a scary time
players were concerned about their own
health they were concerned concerned
about their families health and
especially at the college level where
there wasn't a strong collective
cohesive presence with standards that
were the same at every school you never
really knew what the protections were
going to be especially when it's time to
play and you may be facing a school that
had far looser guidelines than your
university had so there has been some
sound this week from various folks in
the nfl about the opt out dynamic let's
hear first from steelers general manager
kevin colbert on this issue of opt-outs
and how it affects the steelers
evaluation of the players they may or
may not be drafting
as i stated in the summer if a player
chooses to opt out for whatever reason
that's their decision and we we will
respect it however if a player played in
2020
and those players are of equal value one
that didn't play and one had played
we'll take the one it played
because we don't know what the opt-outs
will be like in their first season back
in football we believe it's hard to sit
this game out sometimes it happens
because of injury
but this time it was you know it was
pandemic related for the most part but
we will take the players again if
they're close and it's not to say we're
not going to draft somebody that opted
out
i couldn't say that but if i have a
choice and we have a choice we'll take
the one that played if their value was
close
you know that's a minefield for teams to
walk through i know of at least one top
10 team where if you opted out the mere
fact that you opted out is viewed as a
negative they're never going to admit
that and i only want to name who it is
even though i don't think it would be a
big deal because i know it's true
but i can understand
saying
hey
ultimately if we've got two guys who are
rated exactly the same and i guess it
happens more often than you realize
where you know there isn't a formula you
can punch in to give you 97.23 versus
97.21 hey this guy's the winner
i get it that you're going to err on the
side of the guy that played last year
but you're necessarily punishing the guy
who didn't play
but you got to pick one of them that's
the problem you got two to choose from
all things are equal one played last
year and one didn't i guess i understand
it it's just hard to harmonize that with
we respect the decision to opt out yeah
we respect it we're just not going to
draft you we're going to draft the guy
who's the exact same as you but played
last year
well and what's weird to me about that
and i get what he's saying but what's
weird to me about that mike
is the fact that he talks about injured
players some players missile
i would rather have a guy who opted out
coming to my team than a guy who was
injured all year that hey may or may not
that acl may or may not be ready that
achilles may or may not be 100 may or
may not come back so if if it's me
drafting i have more concern about a
player who missed last season because of
an injury than because of opting out
could they have some rust yeah
absolutely but
you're not drafting these guys for one
year mike if you're especially if you're
drafting a guy in the first round you're
drafting a guy that you hope is going to
be with you 10 plus years right you hope
you're using that fifth round up fifth
year option on him and he that he stays
for a really long time with you so this
is not a one year decision so kind of
weird to me that that teams feel like
this especially when some of these guys
who opted out did it for very good
reasons
and and the other side of it too you
could say if if one guy played and one
guy didn't and he didn't play because
of the pandemic he's got more tread on
the tires i mean there is a different
way to look at this yeah it's actually
better if you didn't play because we
know what you can do the reason you're
even with the guy that played last year
is because of when you played before
that we're satisfied you're in shape you
didn't show up looking like dave
gettleman at your pro day workout that
was gentleman's line last week they look
like me some of them do so if you're in
the basic shape and they can bring you
into the system
if you're a running back for example i'd
rather have a running back who didn't
have 2 000 rushing yards on 400 touches
and get banged around all year long i'd
rather have a guy who didn't have that
wear and tear because running backs only
have so much before the wheels come off
between college and pro so yeah you know
they're
there there's just something about it
that bothers me the idea that it would
be viewed as a negative because that's
the implicit it's the nick saban ands
and butts he's a great player and he
played last year he's a great player but
he didn't play last year and that butt
means that it's viewed in a negative way
let's hear from jerry jones as well on
this issue of what it means for the
players who chose not to play in 2020
but you've got to take that in
consideration too if you've uh
if you guys had not very much exposure
guess what
he may not have played last year may
could have but he didn't
okay he didn't because he decided to opt
out so you haven't seen him since the
six plays he ran when he was a sophomore
[Music]
let's hold him while you're getting
ready to make that decision right there
[Music]
there's a little more
something implied in that than kevin
colbert kevin colbert at least had a a
reasoned explanation we may not agree
with the substance of it you could argue
the reverse of it
but but jerry
i don't know am i misreading what he
said and didn't say i think what he
didn't say was even more important it
was kind of like yeah you know what if
the guy doesn't play well you know he
didn't play and you know
i know they're walking a fine line there
but i think a lot of these teams
are going to have a hard time not
viewing the decision to not play
as
a con not a pro
for the guys that they may or may not
draft shireen
and how many teams how many times mike
do we see a guy redshirt his first year
right and he might play a little bit as
a redshirt freshman and then he plays as
a sophomore a full year and then he
comes out what's i don't know what's
different than that okay he spent three
years there in the film room in the
meeting room all that i get that but he
wasn't on the field it wasn't like he
was getting reps which is something that
jerry pointed out and furthermore let's
look at some of the cowboys second round
picks that they've taken flyers on sean
lee randy gregory jalen smith i mean
those guys were coming off of injuries
jaylen smith didn't play for a whole
year sean lee was injured for much of
the start of his career randy gregory
has been in and out of suspension now
he's back on the team so they've rolled
the dice on a lot of players and so to
say you're not going to roll the dice on
on a player who opted out of last season
i i really don't get that
jerry said that of the guys who didn't
play last year they're compromised i'd
much rather have seen the reps and the
plays they got coach help me out here
how many plays in a normal situation
would a defensive tackle be playing last
year as opposed to not playing mike
mccarthy said 71 plays 10 games so 700
plays jerry said and plus usually those
players they're the type of player you
want are better from their junior to
their senior year fair to say absolutely
mccarthy says so that's what you look
for jerry said the point is you won't
have as much information if they didn't
play
last year but if what you saw
based on the prior year is good enough
for them to otherwise be in a spot where
you're going to draft them
and you think hey they would have been
even better last year so they're going
to get better once they're in the nfl
i i i oh god you know i just feel like
this is all code for we want robots who
submit
and if you chose not to play last year
you showed us that you are willing to
push back against the system against the
grain and think for yourselves and we
don't want
guys who think for themselves we don't
want guys who are going to ask why when
they're told to do something we want
guys who are just going to do what we
want them to do i can't help but think
shireen that that is the message
that is kind of even and i love kevin
colbert but he's it's just it's it's
that's the way football is
see the shining sea every level what do
you want you don't want free thinkers
you don't want a guy who's going to go
off and do his own thing you want guys
who are going to fall in line
do what they're told and not create
distractions for the coach by asking
questions about why the coach is doing
what he's doing or why the players are
being asked to do something that maybe
they don't think they should do i feel
like at some level
that's part of this
so why don't you have a problem with
guys who opt out of the bowl game right
i mean that became a big discussion when
christian mccaffrey did it i don't it
didn't hurt him right he's been a great
player in this league until last year
when he got hurt part of the year so as
much of a problem as it is for these
guys opting out according to some in the
nfl mike i think a bigger problem is not
having the combine and i am wondering if
they had gone to indianapolis if they
had done all the medical stuff if they
had run the 40 dash on 40 yard dash on a
similar surface would these concerns
have evaporated would they have gone
away because they saw them in a
different setting up close
maybe we don't know that but i know a
lot of guys missed the medical who they
had hoped to be there and they didn't
get those medical reports so they're
rolling to dice on some of those guys
who have medical problems and they're
rolling the dice that these 40-yard dash
times run on fast services at the school
are legit
yeah i agree with you completely and
look for the players who opted out and
if they think it's going to be held
against them bottom line is if you don't
draft me someone else will and those
players may end up being even more
motivated and having better careers than
they would have had and those teams will
say crap we we shouldn't have
viewed it as a negative that the guy
chose not to play because he was
concerned about his family's health his
own health and just not knowing how
things were going to play out in the
2020 season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports